well it's been an excruciating hold on a
sec two months since our last Pinocchio
movie and Hollywood can't seem to get
enough
father when can I leave to be on my own
following in the footsteps of Disney's
animated classic the live action remake
and whatever the hell this is acclaimed
director Guillermo del Toro has thrown
his hat into the ring in telling the
story of a boy whose appendage gets
bigger the more he tells lies so
basically the superpower I wanted as a
teenager and who better to tell the
story than the guy who created this join
me as we take a deep dive into this
Fantastical tale and I promise I won't
tell a lie I can't lie now you might
think the main character of this tale is
Pinocchio heck the movie's even named
after him but Pinocchio himself doesn't
even show up until 20 minutes into the
movie I think the main character is
actually Pinocchio's father Geppetto
he's the character who goes through the
biggest fundamental change he's voiced
by David Bradley who you might remember
from Harry Potter or Game of Thrones
unlike other versions of the Pinocchio
tail Del Toro spends the First Act of
the movie recounting The Story of
Geppetto and his son Harlow the two
shared an Inseparable Bond working
together and enjoying life until in 1916
during World War One Carlo is killed by
a military bomber Ironically in a place
Meant For Peace a church earlier Carlo
found the perfect pine cone which
Geppetto will bury next to Carlo's grave
and will grow into a tree that will be
used to create Pinocchio in fact the
first and last image of the movie is a
Pinecone a symbol of Life Geppetto even
tells Carlo when they chop down a tree
but one life is plus another must grow
this cycle of life and death is
something highlighted throughout the
movie as we'll see Pinocchio die and
resurrect several times it's ironic
since there's even a moment in the film
where he looks up to Christ on a
crucifix and wishes he could be like him
the biblical figure who also resurrected
both Geppetto and Christ's Father Joseph
not to mention Christ himself were
Carpenters so there's a lot of religious
symbolism at play here at least 20 years
past since the death of Carlo in 1916
and the arrival of Jiminy Cricket or
should I say Sebastian J Cricket pretty
sure Disney still holds the rights for
Jiminy so they had to change it
Sebastian is a writer looking for a nice
place of solitude to write his Memoirs
so where does he settle the very tree
Geppetto chops down one drunken night
after getting mad at God for not
answering his prayers I mean we've all
been there right in his drunken stupor
Geppetto carves the tree into the shape
of a boy and during the night a spirit
voiced by Tilda Swinton appears now
Sebastian isn't going to give up his
home to this Spirit without a fight so
the spirit offers him a deal if the
cricket promises to watch over and teach
Pinocchio to be good she'll Grant him
one wish Sebastian loves this idea as he
can use this wish to make him a famous
writer Geppetto is understandably
terrified when he finds out his wooden
creation has been brought to life but
isn't so thrilled when the boy
interrupts church service revealing
himself to the town now a lot has
changed since the death of Carlo Benito
Mussolini's fascist regime has taken
control and things aren't as great as
they once were with Pinocchio's reveal
it seems everyone wants to exploit the
boy for their own gain one such
characters count Volpe voiced by
Christoph Waltz
that's a bingo Volpe translates to Fox
and his character is definitely a
predatory one wanting to use Pinocchio
to return his circus and puppet show
back to its Glory Days when Geppetto
finds out Pinocchio has been secretly
performing for the count he goes to
retrieve him and Pinocchio is hit by a
car this is the first of many Pinocchio
deaths because he's not a real boy he's
not bound to the same rules as you and I
in this sort of afterlife world four
black rabbits voiced by Tim Blake Nelson
take Pinocchio to their boss the sister
Spirit to the one we saw at the
beginning of the film she tells him that
he will die many times and that he is
cursed to return over and over again
until eternity after he's brought back
to life we meet another character named
podesta voiced by Del Toro Alum Ron
Perlman he's a fascist government
official who sees the benefit in having
a soldier who can't die Pinocchio would
make a great addition to the Patriotic
youth military project but Geppetto
isn't having it he takes Pinocchio and
on their way home the two get in a fight
all Pinocchio has ever been to him as a
burden and he's nothing like his son
Carlo because I'm not Carlo I don't want
to be like Carlo Carlo in the middle of
the night Pinocchio leaves to join the
circus in his mind this is the perfect
solution to solving the burden problem
he can gain money by working at the
circus while avoiding the war Pinocchio
however still has the naivete of a young
boy and doesn't know that the count is
simply using him and not sending any
money back to his father speaking of his
father he's set out on a quest to find
Pinocchio but on his journey is
swallowed by a giant sea creature this
is a bit of a departure from previous
versions which depict this creature as a
whale meanwhile Pinocchio finds out that
life at the circus isn't all that it's
cracked up to be the count Works them to
the Bone or should I say stump and even
Cuts part of his nose when he sticks up
for the monkey spatziatora who is voiced
by Kate Blanchette spatzatura means
trash in Italian so Pinocchio plans to
ruin the Count's Big Show in front of
Mussolini himself although he has very
little lines Mussolini is performed by
Tom Kenny who voiced SpongeBob these
Antics get Pinocchio killed by Mussolini
and his body brought into the custody of
podesta who trains him to become a
soldier their Pinocchio befriends
Candlewick podesta's son and Candlewick
feels like his father doesn't love him
I'll show him I'm no coward I'll make
him like me it's here Pinocchio learns a
valuable lesson something Cricket tried
to tell him earlier that sometimes those
we love say things they don't mean but
with time
they learned they never really meant it
at all this all goes back to Geppetto
calling Pinocchio a burden something he
may have meant in the moment but didn't
truly mean during a war game Pinocchio
and Candlewick face off against each
other with a game coming out at high
podesta orders his son to shoot
Pinocchio but Candlewick refuses he's
doing what is good and right and whether
he knows it or not standing up to his
father shows just how courageous he is
the camp comes under attack and an
explosion lands Pinocchio right back
into the Count's control the count even
mounts him up on a cross for some added
Christian symbolism it spasitura now who
has the chance to do what is right
fighting off his former master and
shoving him off the cliff Pinocchio and
spaz survive the fall only to be sucked
into the same creature Geppetto's in the
two are reunited and embraced but that
still leaves them with the problem of
escaping the belly of the Beast
Pinocchio's ability to grow his nose
every time he tells a lie comes in handy
here as they're able to use it to tickle
the creatures blowhole and Escape that
sounded weird Pinocchio is sucked in
again but this time along with a c mine
allowing Pinocchio to sacrifice himself
destroying the creature and saving his
father the blast is so powerful
Geppetto's fate is left in the balance
but Pinocchio can't do anything because
he's dead in this version of Pinocchio
he must wait a certain length of time
before he's brought back to life but he
needs to get back to Geppetto right now
to save him there is one solution if
Pinocchio breaks The Hourglass he'll be
resurrected immediately but return as a
mortal essentially meaning this would be
his last life and that's exactly what
Pinocchio does coming back to the real
world and saving Geppetto but dying in
the process it's a selfless act to save
the person he cares for most it's here
Geppetto calls Pinocchio his son for the
first time and instead of wanting
Pinocchio to be the Sun that he lost he
loves Pinocchio for who he is don't be
Carlo or anyone else be exactly who you
are and remember how crooked had one
wish if he turned Pinocchio into a good
boy well he decides to selflessly use
his wish to bring Pinocchio back to life
Geppetto Pinocchio spaz and Cricket live
out the rest of their days as we see
Pinocchio live on as his loved ones one
by one grow old and die he buries his
father in spaz and keeps Cricket's body
in a matchbox in his chest and you may
think this is a sad ending but it's
really quite beautiful they all get to
live the rest of their lives happily
together not much is known about what
happened to Pinocchio after this but
it's said that he too will one day die
and perhaps that will make him a real
boy the movie ends with an acorn falling
highlighting the cycle of life and death
or as the movie puts it what happens
happens
and then
we are gone perhaps the film's biggest
departure from the 1940 film is that
Pinocchio never becomes an actual human
boy rather it questions our notion on
what it means to be real so what did you
think of Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio
should Pinocchio have turned into a real
boy I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone for more bad takes
you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember father when can I leave to
be on my own
foreign